[Música]
esta sección directo a en la que hoy nos
vamos hasta Lima la capital peruana en
este país habló hoy el expresidente
Pedro Castillo quien se pronunció sobre
su situación tras ser detenido el pasado
diciembre de 2022 luego del fallido
autogolpe tras decretar el cierre del
Congreso Castillo aseguró este jueves
ser un preso político que no cometió
ningún acto de rebelión ni menos de
Conspiración porque no se levantó en
armas acusó además al congreso y a la
prensa de no haber aceptado nunca su
Victoria para analizar estas palabras
vamos a conectar con nuestra
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
Francisco Por qué llegan ahora estas
palabras del expresidente desde la
cárcel
Buenas noches algunos juristas sostienen
que la estrategia de Pedro castillo y
sus abogados es tratar de convencer que
la fiscalía no cuenta con pruebas para
acusar a castillo y procesarlo por los
presuntos delitos de rebelión o
conspiración es por eso que el ex
mandatario peruano le dijo hoy a la
justicia de este país en una audiencia
virtual que es un preso político esto
motivó que el juez supremo Juan Carlos
cheque le aclare a Castillo que no es un
preso político y que en realidad se
encuentra en un régimen de prisión
preventiva Y es que la estrategia legal
de Castillo también trata de imponerse
en el escenario internacional con
medidas cautelares ante la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos así
como la Organización de las Naciones
Unidas tal como lo ha señalado la
abogada Indira Rodríguez quien ha
manifestado que cuestionar la vacancia
presidencial el arresto de Pedro
Castillo y su prisión preventiva puede
servir para construir un eventual
ambiente favorable y con eso reponerlo
en el poder
Y ahora cómo avanza este proceso por
presunta corrupción contra Pedro
Castillo pero también contra su entorno
la fiscalía ha presentado una apelación
para insistir en su pedido de prisión
preventiva contra la ex primer ministra
Betsy Chávez en paralelo la justicia
peruana ha programado para el 15 de mayo
una audiencia de prisión preventiva
contra Lilia paredes esposa del
expresidente Pedro Castillo el
Ministerio Público está pidiendo 28
meses de prisión preventiva contra la ex
primera dama por los presuntos delitos
de colusión de organización criminal en
medio de todo esto el Ministerio Público
ha cerrado un acuerdo de colaboración
con salatiel marrufo ex jefe del
gabinete asesores del Ministerio de
vivienda y construcción salatiel marrufo
le ha confesado a la fiscalía que le
entregó un soborno de más de 27 millones
a Pedro castillo y también ha dicho que
el primer el exministro de vivienda y
construcción yaner Alvarado Le entregó a
Castillo más de 123 mil dólares para que
sea mantenido en el cargo Fuentes del
ministerio público señalan que la
fiscalía está construyendo un caso
sólido contra Castillo y su entorno es
por eso que le está solicitando la
justicia de este país sacar hasta la
piel marrufo de prisión preventiva
ponerlo en Libertad bajo el régimen de
comparecencia con restricciones